[Musique]
le rapport ministériel encourage ainsi
la vente de l'aspirine et du paracétamol
en libre service un acte dangereux pour
beaucoup de pharmaciens car ce
médicament peut être mortelle vous avez
là des comprimés de paracétamol et
paracétamol sont toujours conditionné à
500 me g en boîte de 16 alors qu'à une
époque qui est en boîte de 20 il y avait
une incitation très forte à la
consommation et une dangerosité
importante pour ça qu'on a réduit le
contenant des boîtes si aujourd'hui on
doit augmenter la consommation des
médicaments et augmenter le nombre de
boîtes on aura que des inconvénients
santé publique
[Musique]